- He's been looking after himself
since he was 14 years old.
He partnered with Jay Z to
create Roc-A-Fella Records
and changed the hip-hop industry.
He's been involved in businesses
from clothing, to films, to cars.
He's Damon Dash and here are
his top ten rules for success.
(aircraft thundering)
- Nine to fives aren't good because
you hustling for a weekend.
But when you do something
that's for yourself
and your family, it never feels like work.
I hustle for my last name,
I don't hustle for my first.
I've learnt over the years,
that with anything you have to be patient.
Not five years patient,
or five months patient,
you could be ten years
patient if you want.
Empire's aren't built overnight.
I always tell everyone the Great Wall
was a 2,000 year old plan.
2,000, you know how many
lifetimes that is in one plan?
And getting people
to do the same, to have
the same exact agenda
for lifetimes,
for generations, that's crazy.
So, you have to be patient when you want
to do something
significant, no matter what.
A lot of time that means
not reaping the benefits
of something immediately.
And that's the test.
I don't think my approach on business
is what the average person would advise.
I hear people say, "Never
put up your own money,"
and I'm saying put your own money up.
Work harder than everyone, be patient
and just know that if you're
going to do something on your own,
you're going to have to feel some pain.
You always have to have something
that's paying your bills.
So that whatever you're
creating can breathe,
so you don't have to rush it,
you don't have to push it to
make money when it's not ready.
You kind of always have
to have something solid,
that's paying your bills,
'cause even as an artist,
to me as a man, you still
have the responsibility
to take care of your woman,
to take care of your children,
and to take care of yourself.
And you know, almost in that order,
it's like children, your
woman, and then yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
All of that should be taken care of.
That's a real man.
And as an artist, you can't say,
"All right, well, I'm not going
to take care of my children,
or take care of my woman, or
even take care of myself well
to protect my artistry."
Then that's not artistry to
me, that's just being lazy.
I think, as an artist, you have
to fight for that artistry.
You have to figure out
how to pay your bills,
so that the artistry can breathe.
It also, you know, that's
how you feel like a real man.
Have you ever watched a James Bond movie
where it doesn't look like
he's losing at some point?
And then he wins.
Or Batman, or Iron Man, or any superhero?
There has to be some diversity
for you to overcome, to win.
You can't be a champ
unless you're in a place
where you look like you're
going to lose and then you win.
The pain that's going to
come with being independent,
you have to embrace it
because it's going to happen.
Also know that the more
successful you get,
the more problems you're going to have.
The more knots you're
going to have to untie.
Being a boss does not mean smooth sailing,
it means having the ability
to care about other people before yourself
and to untie problems, untie knots.
That's all it is.
It's not business if there's not problems.
There's nothing good without struggle,
it just doesn't happen.
In all my experiences,
there hasn't been one thing
that's been successful
without me feeling some pain
before it was successful.
So now, when there is pain, I embrace it.
I've been embracing it, I'm a G about it,
because I know must
mean, that if I'm cool,
that what awaits me is the
darkness before the dawn.
I don't want to sound corny
but that's really what has to happen.
I'm always going to play fair,
I don't believe in doing
anything, unless it's fair,
because I believe there are
always karmic repercussions
from doing things unfair,
so what can appear to be a win,
or something that appears
to be a fast, you know,
fast money, I know in the
long run I'm going to suffer.
That it's always a test.
Anything quick is a test.
I can get it quick if
I don't have to cheat,
but if I've got to cheat to get it fast,
I don't want it.
My parents haven't bought me
clothes since I was about 14.
I haven't had nobody buy
me nothing, let's say that.
No one's taken care of me
since I was 14 years old.
And I didn't want nobody taking care of me
'cause they couldn't.
What they was trying to buy
me, I wasn't trying to wear.
Taste, talent, and work ethic.
I need all of it.
Taste, talent, work ethic,
you know, perspective.
So when I interview, or even
when the people I work with
find more talent, they have to bring me,
I have to get a mix tape from them,
I need to know what music
they're listening to
'cause taste in music
tells a lot about a person.
It really does.
I got to know who their
favorite designer is.
What's the last book they
read, favorite artist.
And it's funny, 'cause sometimes
you get those (laughs),
the answers are hilarious
but people be trying, you know,
but you honestly have to have,
I look for all your
senses to be activated,
you know what I mean?
I need you to have good taste in music,
I need you to have work ethic,
I need you to be a good person,
I need you to have good taste in clothes.
You need to be able to be savvy
in more than just one thing.
Everyone in my staff can do, like,
there's not one job that
anyone does in my staff.
If I make a regular business
that doesn't touch pop culture
and doesn't make history,
then, to some people,
that would be considered going backwards.
That's not a pressure for me
because I could care
less what people think.
I don't think there's
anything about my career,
where you would think I
did it for someone else.
I'm just constantly
trying to impress myself.
I've accomplished, relatively
speaking, a lot of things.
And because of that,
I've been able to do
exactly what inspires me.
Everyone has the ability
to take care of themselves.
You can always be a hunter,
you can always eat the food you kill.
It's just about how lazy you are.
You know what I'm saying?
Period.
It's all about your effort.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
My question of the day for you is,
do you agree with Damon Dash,
that you need to put up your own money
to be an entrepreneur?
Leave a comment below, I'm
curious to see what you think.
Now, I made this video
because Jose Cruz asked me to,
so, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile, leave a comment underneath
and I'll see what I can do.
If you like this video
and you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to
the newsletter and the channel.
Have a great day, continue to believe
and I hope you'll join me again,
tomorrow at 7:00 a.m. Eastern,
for another video to
help you start your day
on the right foot.
(aircraft thundering)